Her low freak bitches.
It really does bring to
mind this incredible verse
in the Bhagavad Gita where
Krishna is revealing his true form to
our June who's like the warrior figure.
And uh,
this is Oppenheimer's quote,
this is Oppenheimer's quote.
When he did,
he said after the atomic bomb went off,
and I'm a quoted this part of
the Bhagavad Gita where he said,
I have become death,
the destroyer of worlds,
but it doesn't stop there.
Krishna's sang to Argentina,
something along the lines of,
look in my teeth there you will see them,
everyone on this battlefield
because I'm eating them right now.
So this is like,
this is like Chris,
it'd be like,
oh,
you really want to see what I'm saying?
Cause they've just been friends hanging
out and stuff and he like suddenly
became the force of all
destruction in the known universe.
And the point of the thing was,
listen,
all of this is already chewed up.
It's already been devoured.
It's already gone.
Game over.
You're done.
No Kurzweil is going to
get you new blood cells.
It's going to keep this going
to keep you alive at some point.
I will come to you wearing
the costume of your death.
And that is an inevitability.
So just surrender to that and you're
going to be a lot less freaked out if you
just accept that that's the way it is.
Because if your war that you're engaged
in right now is the war to live forever.
If you're a war that you're engaged in
right now is a war to try to make some
lasting change in a universe that's
defined by impermanence and change,
then you're fighting the wrong war.
There's a better war to fight,
you know,
and it's actually the way you
fight it is by surrendering,
not by fighting,
by letting go and sinking into
the actual hum of the universe,
the way it really works,
not the way you wish it work,
not the way that you are hoping
that the universe worked where uh,
you know,
lions and hyenas rescue
little boys like air,
like an ice age,
but the cartoon.
But the way it actually works,
the way the university actually works
as everything comes into existence,
it exists for a little
while and then it dies
than most things come out of explosions,
eh?
Oh yeah.
Don't forget that.
Yeah.
Most things come out of big fucking blast,
including the whole universe itself.
Yes.
Right.
Whole Universe itself is
predicated upon a violent event.
Yeah.
It has to have a violent event.
Right.
That's big bang.
It couldn't be the slow expansion of
beautiful life giving particles throughout
the universe now,
nope.
It's a big fucking bang.
No,
it was a big fucking bang and it keeps it,
it keeps going.
The big bank keeps going and is,
but it's just like this,
man.
If you want to dig your heels in and sync
your claws into the expanding universe
and try to keep that fucking
thing from expanding,
you're going to get ripped apart.
That's just the way it works.
But if you want to let go
and merge into the thing,
if you want to allow yourself the fantasy
that you're not some individual with a
social security number
and a name and parents,
but allow yourself the fantasy that
you're 13.8 billion years old and you're
part of this incredible ocean of happening
instead of just this one individual,
and just let yourself
experience that for a second.
The glorious knowledge that
you are a never ending,
ever changing flow of matter that's
temporarily manifested with the ability to
express love and do a dimension where
things are supposed to be cooling off,
then that's a fun way to spend your time
here before you end up getting eaten by
a lion or have a heart
attack or whatever happens.
It's just a backflip.
This is uh,
this is like a high dot.
This is like when you see people come
off of a high dive and you get like a few
seconds.
It's just some cool fucking tricks.
That's what you get here.
We're like dolphins jumping out of the
eternal and we into time and while we
were shoot up into time,
we get a chance to do
a couple of back flips,
a couple of Chirps,
and that's our life's work.
And then we plunged back
into infinity again.
Do it all over again.
It's like if you're creating characters
for fiction and the idea that you can't
create a con,
you know you can't make a slot.
You can't make a girl who's
all fucked up in the head.
Well they,
they exist in life.
Okay.
And if you're making fiction,
your fiction doesn't necessarily have to
represent anything other than what's in
your head.
What's the wacky story
you're trying to get out?
You don't have any obligation to
use a certain amount of Asians.
You don't have any obligation to use a
certain amount of white people or black
people.
Your obligation is to
make something cool up,
make it up,
pull it out of your head.
Well look,
people are worried about
entertainment like that.
That's a very,
that one I was religious.
That was our,
well,
Jehovah's Witness Dude,
like every fucking thing
I watched like smart,
like a smurfs was off limits for
some fucking bullshit reason.
Right.
They wouldn't let you watch the SMURFS.
Yeah.
I mean,
so what it really,
but there's,
I don't know where there's some demonic
thing with that and it's all these
fucking,
and then,
uh,
I remember the Simpsons,
somebody came in and gave a talk,
brother Tucker,
his name was,
he was like,
the traveling overseer was his title.
Right.
And he would come and like
give talks in the congregate.
I was in meetings like
three nights a week.
So he gave this whole fucking
talk about all the shit that,
like how Iti was bad because he,
yeah,
because he healed the boy and you're like,
you know,
who do we know is the
only person who can heal?
Like I might start believing
ut is the real Jesus.
That's the fear.
And then the Simpsons had
rebellion against authority
with bar and disrespect of
like your elders.
So that's something I
could hear the mother's,
well,
I'm not like my kid.
Watch it.
I could hear them chattering after that.
Like that's what this shit is now.
It's like what is,
what's the representation?
It's not propaganda.
So Shit,
just candy.
You know.
So we were talking about
this before the podcast to,
do you think that some like overtly upset
PC people that what they're doing is
almost like a form of like protecting
almost like a form of fighting against
blasphemy that like I
remember it goes to my church,
I remember all of them that were like,
oh well you something
like every logistical one,
that same behavior.
I believe that 100% I think you're right.
You is the exact same thing.
Yeah.
I don't even listen.
I don't even mind them.
As long as you are trying to get me fired,
I don't it,
you can say whatever you know.
But if you want to criticize,
I'm not against criticism.
Right,
right.
That's fine.
Just do I have to be fired?
Just can we not do that part of it?
Well that,
that,
that is where you find out like
exactly what kind of people they are.
Like what exactly are
they trying to accomplish?
Are they trying to engage in
discourse with a reasonable person?
You're reasonable guy,
you'll have conversations with people,
but that's the thing they
want you instantly labeled
as an unreasonable person
who's not to be debated.
Well,
you shouldn't even have to bring it up.
You should just know what
the right thing is to do.
Remember the Anti Seinfeld Seinfeld,
Chris Rock said the same thing,
right?
Yeah.
But he's allowed to.
That was not an in Seinfeld
comes down and it's like,
well,
he's irrelevant and an old man something,
which by the way,
that's like saying someone's fat.
Yeah.
I don't see the difference
in that common him.
Right.
Yeah.
I mean it's diffusing his,
his argument and what he's saying is,
you know,
what Jerry Seinfeld was saying was that
the colleges are too PC and they'll call
you on everything with his
daughter of these days.
They don't even know what the fuck these
words mean and what constitutes that.
Right.
And that's exactly right.
That's the,
I don't think that PC ruins comedy.
Like people who are funny are still funny.
It kind of fucks up audiences.
Right?
So we both,
I have the same goals,
one of these PC Beulah.
I think people should be more sensitive
to each other and all that shit I do as
well.
But their system is not
going to create that.
It's just going to create fucking
people that shut down at buzzwords.
Right.
So that's not helping.
Okay.